there's two camps there's a camp that
says desantis won't run directly against
trump and there's a camp that says no
he's gonna run because the opportunity
is so hot right now for desantis with
the record he's at in florida last two
years this is a perfect time for for him
to run where do you stand with that
first of all he needs to get himself
reelected he's got a contest this
november uh he should not take that for
granted i think he's favored but
florida's not a red state and it's not a
blue state it's a purple state
and the governor's poll is very popular
i'm certainly going to vote for his
re-election but he's also very
polarizing uh so uh you know richard
nixon lost the presidency in 1960
decided to run for governor in 1962 on
his way to the 64 nomination
something went wrong didn't get elected
governor and that was the end of that
comeback attempt interesting desantis i
think would be wise to pay attention to
the contest before him uh before he gets
ahead of himself
uh this is uh
i i he would be a formidable candidate i
i don't deny that
um but uh he is he doesn't have the
charisma that trump has he doesn't have
the the uh the presence that
that trump has
the governor is very good in a
controlled atmosphere when he has the
microphone and nobody else does he does
great
but he's not self-deprecating he's not
funny he's not entertaining he's kind of
stiff
he said trump's self-deprecating
all the time yeah absolutely trump makes
jokes about himself and you say desantis
is kind of a stiff kind of a stiff i
mean he's very focused he's very
disciplined which is a key factor in
politics
but he's not very charismatic he's a
little boring he's a little boring is
care is charisma the most important
quality a president could have we live
in the television age you know they
asked ronald reagan
do you think it was detrimental to your
your
prospects to be president that you were
an actor and he said you know
i don't see how a guy who wasn't an
actor could ever do this job this is in
1980
when he was president
i don't see someone who's not an actor
can do this job can you imagine that
line for reagan to say which which makes
sense okay is rick in the the trump camp
where do you stand on this you live in
florida so you probably have strong
opinions on desantis trump all that well
i i voted for trump both times i think
that he has put together the best
policies for this country i love his
patriotism
i love his support for law enforcement
and of course for our military special
military and law enforcement and federal
agencies
i also like desantis i think that he's
done an incredible job here in florida
and i've talked to a lot of people about
this a lot of people don't want the
dissenters to run because they don't
want him to leave florida
it's a very selfish place has been very
vocal about that you know that's that's
a big concern a lot of floridians have
but i think i think the biggest question
is the following and i'm curious to know
what you say about this so you know how
uh uh in mma or in boxing certain people
that come from the same camp you know
they don't fight each other and then if
they do there's a big you know a rift
there's a big follow now between the two
yeah massive adult had a following out
with kobe they used to come from the
same camp so if you follow mma you both
you know you so you hear stories like
that
what what do you so visualize the stage
which is what everybody is
wanting to see if it's going to happen
or not oh first republican you know uh
presidential debate on the republican
side okay so we're looking at all the
candidates on stage you're gonna see say
rubio maybe cruz you see all the
candidates that we see right they're on
the stage maybe mayor suarez i don't
know but you got these names on the
stage right they're debating
everybody knows it's really two names
it's not any other names the other guys
are up there just to kind of be up there
but we know it's only two names
do you remember the scene when kamala
harris went right after biden do you
remember that one scene when kamala
hurst went after bussing back yeah 80s
and then surprisingly she ends up
becoming a vp which is a very weird
thing that happens but
what happens when these two go at it you
know what happens when they call each
other out who calls each other who calls
who out first
how is the market going to take it how
are republicans going to take it how are
democrats going to use it
how are the other side going to be
prepared let's just say trump takes a
shot at desantis is desantis going to
come out strong towards trump if
desantis comes up first and takes a shot
at trump is trump gonna come out and
bully him like he typically does is that
good for the party have they spoken
prior do are they gonna call each other
out and say listen hey desantis we know
it's you and i
uh let's take it easy on each other is
that gonna be the conversation or trump
going to say nah i'm not going to do
that we're going at it who's going to
win how do you see this happening well
there's not too many questions there
first of all it's two years from now and
two years
is a lifetime in politics a month is a
lifetime in politics
governor sanchez did not fare very well
in his two debates with mayor gillum
again an uncontrolled atmosphere
he does very well in a controlled
atmosphere where he has the podium and
the microphone trump will be
entertaining always entertaining uh and
that's that's very important uh in our
culture i mean politics is entertainment
the worst thing in politics to be is
boring trump is never boring
um but to handicap something that's two
years from now is extraordinarily
different uh difficult
well you did that 30 years though you
you handicapped 30 years prior to trump
being president i was disabled that's
even more difficult i was just actually
able to see a you know a prime piece of
political horse flash i was prepared to
see a guy who i thought had the size i
don't mean the physical size but the
presence uh and the courage and the
stamina uh
and the willingness to say anything to
be an interesting uh and provocative not
only candidate but then have the courage
to be a strong president
trump
broke the mold i mean pride before trump
we had no president who wasn't a general
or a senator or a governor
we never had a business person as
president so
on paper trump shouldn't be able to win
he broke all of the rules didn't spend
millions of dollars on network
television advertising still got elected
president so um i still think he's the
favorite
on the other side of the coin
not to not to shock you but my
prediction on the democratic nominee for
president in 2024
michelle obama
almost certainly i agree
you're saying most certainly yeah i i
mean this book tour she said yesterday
yeah
yeah she's out there being very go ahead
she's very active right now she's out
doing this book tour these voter
registration drives and so on
she's certainly not doing for the money
so no i think she's positioning herself
and by the way i think she'll be a very
formidable candidate do you think she
could beat trump
too far away um are gas prices the same
as they are today or do we have food
shortages are we still dying from this
rampant inflation uh are we are we
shipping 40 billion dollars to ukraine
when we can't spend five and seven point
six seven million to seal our southern
border i mean
the the issue situation today would
favor any republican in the at least in
the next election round and perhaps the
following round but again
reagan had a sour economy in the middle
of his first term the economy was
roaring by the end of his first term and
he got reelected so meaning if things
change and powell increasing the rates
doing what he does
maybe flattens in
inflation and then he can lower interest
rates a little bit so then we go back to
having a decent economy
and gas prices go lower everything is
now a little bit more settled you think
the likelihood of biden getting
re-elected
is higher or you just don't think he's
going to run against i don't see him
running again okay
so no matter what on the left it's going
to be somebody else outside of biden is
what you're saying that is my belief
yeah do you also agree absolutely who do
you think it's going to be
i don't know and the news of michelle
obama scares me because she is um i
consider her a very drastic left-wing
individual
you know from from my and i'm not a
politician that's obvious but from my
perspective
you know the the far right is always
going to vote for right and the far left
is always going to vote left so we need
a candidate especially in our republican
party somebody that could bring in that
middle america
you know that average american out there
that finally cannot afford to be yeah
the silent majority anymore and become a
not so silent majority
well are you are you going to when you
said that are you saying desantis is
that kind of where you were going with
them no neither one either one okay i i
um
let the best man win but i know which
way i would be voting would be still
that way but but let me ask you a
question roger from your from your uh
having done this for a while how often
do do candidates leading candidates of
the same party talk to each other before
the first debate oh almost always and
what does that call sound like what's
that conversation sound like
you know it can be like the way off in a
in a prize fight you know they can trash
talk each other or but i think the
i think the president's kind of
nonchalant about this he was quoting the
new yorker last week as saying look it's
his prerogative if he runs he runs i'll
beat him
i think that's the right attitude
got it but it's not deals are not made
pre or our deals made pre-first
debate that takes place i don't think
everybody makes a deal because everybody
goes into that debate thinking i'm the
guy
this is my opportunity to break through
maybe i'm back in the pack right now but
this is my opportunity to break through
the field will win oh pretty close
pretty quickly because
trump is so completely dominant the only
one as you correctly pointed out
who potentially is a challenger who can
get anything together uh is ron desantis
i mean
mike pompeo who out on the street in
front of the uh of the studio and that's
the first seven people you see who mike
pompeo is they don't even know who marco
rubio is and we live in florida so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]